I have been privileged today to give a
talk on atheism and I'd first like to
thank the hosts for having us here and
for accommodating us so that we can give
these very important talks about some
very important topics prior to getting
into the discussion it's one a little
bit about myself I hold two degrees in
philosophy and one of my specialties has
been atheism in fact my master's thesis
was in atheism and you're probably
wondering first question in your mind is
why did I choose a degree in philosophy
and I'd like to tell myself that the
reason I did so is because I wanted to
discover the mysteries of humanity and
purpose and life but the reality is
usually I'm just thinking long deep
thoughts about unemployment and other
such things my own existential crises
that said I want to clarify that I'm not
going to give you guys a long convoluted
argument for God's existence I'm not
going to be presenting any sort of
logical deductions or anything of the
sorts so I don't want you to worry for
those of you who are not familiar with
my field what I do intend to do however
is I want to talk about atheism in a way
that I feel is really most important to
how a lot of young Muslims are dealing
with the concept or dealing with the
issue today and that's from a
psychological and pragmatic perspective
and what I mean by those things is not
simply emotions but what it means to
experience doubts in today's world what
it means to be entrapped by these doubts
and want to move towards atheism so I
want to discuss not only it's sort of
the motivations behind going towards
atheism but how atheists tend to think
about these things and from a
psychological and pragmatic perspective
and how were to deal with them in that
way in that manner I am NOT an
individual who actually believes that
you can convince most people
logical arguments I don't think it works
that way I've been dealing with atheists
for the majority of my life not the
majority my life excuse me ruining my
career that would be interesting though
and I have never found or at least most
of the time maybe 99% of time I've never
found that atheists are usually
convinced by intellectual arguments it's
usually has to do with a lot of
emotional and psychological issues so I
want to discuss three primary issues
today the first one being the problem of
evil
the second being the problem of
representation and thirdly the problem
of belief or knowledge so with regard to
the first one the problem of evil what
is the problem of evil well it's very
simple people look at the world around
them and they see horrible things
happening on a daily basis if you're a
Muslim especially this is nothing new to
you in fact Muslims I think experience
more evil than most people today we look
at Myanmar we look at Syria we look at
Yemen we look at Iraq Muslims are
constantly faced with these dilemmas are
constantly faced with these issues where
they are seeing people dying starving or
being violated in the most horrendous
ways possible hence why you also have an
issue within the Muslim youth about this
particular problem the problem of evil
and the way it is often addressed is
that because there is so much evil and
there is such an all-powerful God that
exists apparently why isn't he doing
anything about it why is he just sitting
around obviously you know just letting
it all happen for no reason when he has
the power to just decimate all evil
within the moment within just a second
even less than that
why is he allowing all this to occur and
as a result of that these questions fill
our minds and many people tend to go
down the route that well him maybe he
doesn't exist what evidence is there
that he does exist if he has so much
power and concern for us why is he not
doing anything therefore he just
maybe is just a fiction in my mind maybe
it's just a myth but I always found this
to be a very curious doubt for many
reasons first off when we look at the
quran surah Baqarah ayah 30 in
particular we find that allah subhanho
wa taala especially well release new
islam traditions but in the Islamic
tradition God is very very explicit
he's very explicit about why evil exists
and also how to deal with it and very
much like humans initially react to evil
the Angels also reacted to evil when it
was presented to them they react in a
very similar manner they saw it they saw
that a loss upon what thought it was
going to create something someone that
was going to create a lot of corruption
and bloodshed on the earth and the
angels asked him why are you doing this
and a lot responded very simply I know
what you do not now that seems like a
very simple answer but it's a very
profound answer one that we should
really think about because it has a
number of implications the first of
those being that Allah is telling you
explicitly that it's not a problem
he's telling you that it's not a problem
for him it's not an issue I know what
you do not I have it under control don't
worry about it that's the first explicit
answer the second one is he saying is
that there is a purpose I know what you
do not I know why I'm doing this there
is a purpose behind that evil and
finally he's also saying that I know
what you do not because I am the only
one who can rectify it I'm the only one
who can solve whatever is in your heart
what is it whatever that problem is what
you think is an issue is not an issue
for me because I will deal with it maybe
not in the way that you want me to maybe
not immediately maybe not in the manner
that you think is appropriate but I will
that's why I'm allowing it to exist to
begin with
and you would think that that would be
sufficient but many people don't
consider it to be sufficient and I
always thought that's really weird why
why do people still feel that atheism is
a far more rational position to take
than to accept that God is there
overseeing everything despite all the
horrible things that we see on a daily
basis because to me if you adopt atheism
the problem of evil does not go away
it doesn't suddenly vanish from the face
of the earth you still have evil the
moment that you have rid God it doesn't
be this this The Situation's
happening in Syria and Iraq and Libya
and Yemen
they don't just magically disappear
they're still there women are still
raped children are still starved to
death innocent men are shot and killed
horrible things that keep occurring
regardless if God is there or not in
your mind it's still a problem so what
have you solved the existential angst
that an atheist would feel is still
there he still sees evil except now that
evil and here's where it becomes worse
that evil is no longer rectified and it
no longer has a purpose you no longer
have a God saying I'm gonna deal with it
you no longer have a God saying it's
gonna get solved that woman stays raped
that child stays starved and that man
stays dead and murdered without any
justice for all of eternity that seems a
far more depressing standard for the
problem of evil then when you bring God
into the equation but then when I bring
this up to a lot of atheists they tell
me well we can solve the problem because
I can make my own meaning and I can make
my own purpose for what evil means and
how to solve it and you hear this a lot
from atheist we make our own meaning and
our employers our own purpose and I
always found that very curious as well
really
so you reject religion for being a
man-made myth but you're willing to make
more myths then why even become an
atheist to begin with if it's all the
same stay a Muslim because in the end of
the day it's still a myth right
pragmatically it makes no sense
economically it makes no sense in an
intellectual standpoint you still get
the same results at the end of the day
you're still baking but of course as
Muslims we believe these things to be
true but the atheist admits to having to
make up his own truth in order to
compensate I find that to be a very weak
position to hold but you don't see even
more interesting about the problem of
evil if the problem of evil is actually
a problem then we should hypothesize
something we should hypothesize that
those who suffer the most should be the
most susceptible to not believing in God
however we find the opposite the people
in Syria the people in Iraq the people
in Libya the people in Yemen the people
in Myanmar still look up to the sky and
say la ilaha illa llah despite the fact
that they've lost their families their
homes that they're refugees that they're
starving because that is the only thing
that gives them any sort of hope it
gives them any sort of willpower to keep
moving
or
you would think that because they are
suffering the most that they would be
the first to leave it but they do not it
is the only thing that keeps them human
and you see the only people who seem to
be complaining about the problem of evil
are those individuals who live in
relative luck oops in other words a
bunch of fedora tipping trolls who have
nothing else to do with their time then
complain on Facebook on the internet
about the problem of evil problems that
they have never experienced themselves
fascinator fascinating problem that you
have never dealt with but others have
and yet they still call out to God
something to think about and this moves
on to the second point that I want to
bring out which is the problem of
representation and what does that mean
people have a tendency to accept or
reject beliefs based on the
representatives so for example people
see Isis and they assume that this is
somehow representative of Islamic
teachings okay you have a lot of
individuals who will experience a
traumatic event through either their
family members who happen to be Muslim
or others around them who happen to know
Muslim and then they go this must be the
religion as a result of that I have to
leave this cannot be something that I
can follow because other people are
following it and they're doing bad
things but this has always seemed like a
very curious position to me very curious
problem first off how do you determine
an ideology based on what people say
about it or act in its name let me give
you an example of why I find this to be
absurd does anybody know what the formal
name of North Korea is the Democratic
Republic Democratic People's Republic of
Korea the Democratic People's Republic
of Korea
they are the ISIS of democracy but
nobody uses them as a standard to judge
democratic principles why why
why is that is it convenience perhaps
does anybody judge the United States
Constitution based on right-wing
politics no at least no sane individual
does does anybody judge policies of
socialism based on China based on what
they're doing what they used to do no
but only when it comes to Islam somehow
individuals all of a sudden become
representatives become the actual
manifestation of Islamic teachings which
I find to be a curious double standard
likewise a similar double standard is
that these same individuals who tend to
have doubts about Islam never look in
history they always like to be enamored
with the West they like to look at
Western technology in science and
there's stability within domestic realm
and they tend to say well this must be
because of Western or secular liberal
ethics but a hundred years ago that was
not the case 100 years ago secular
liberal ethics led to numerous genocides
and a hundred years ago the Muslim world
was still one of the most powerful
empires that existed so it seems to me
that these same individuals would have a
hundred years ago become Muslim as a
result of the situation being reversed
which is very strange how to pick a
standard of belief based on these
constant changes
likewise what I find interesting about
this problem people psychologically is
how they never seem to think about their
own standards and how they view for
example Western societies and I find
this among Muslims especially I'm sure
all of you have all heard this platitude
before because when I first converted to
Islam this is the first thing that I
heard as well when you go to Muslim
countries you find lots of Muslims but
no Islam but when you go to Western
countries you find no Muslims but you
find this LOM and I thought that was
very clever at first and then I thought
about it and it ended up not being very
clever because what are you talking
about I used to ask a lot of examples
who told me this and they said well if
you go to the West you see a lot of
stability a lot of festival 'ti and
technology and progress and things like
this I said ok but what about how the
West treats other nations what about the
fact that they're slaughtering other
people overseas is that also part of
Islam is that something you have convene
leave forgotten a civilization it's not
simply based on how it treats its own
members but how it treats others the
sort of logic that is employed there is
no different than than praising a serial
killer for being a good family man oh
you know Bob he slaughtered half the
neighborhood but you should see how he
treats his mom and his parents and his
family does pretty he's a great guy
nobody thinks that way but for some
reason when it comes to Western
societies we seem to only adulate how
they treat its own members rather than
looking at it as a whole so I find it
very curious why people are drawn to
atheism or opposed to religion on the
basis of looking at it representatives
of other cultures it's a lot of double
standards there now for my third point
and I think it's the most important one
is the problem of belief today you have
many people especially within theist
intellectual
additions that will suggest that
everything requires evidence everything
requires a rational standard of belief
especially science science is prime is
the primary standard ok you often hear
this especially online and I find this a
very curious position and why do I find
it very curious because 90% of the
things that make us human are not proven
scientifically
one of the things I often asked atheist
when they tell me that I need to prove
God through scientific reasoning is do
you believe in human rights human rights
they say yes I do and then I asked them
can you give me a peer-reviewed
scientific journal that proves the
existence of human rights they say no I
cannot and I said then why do you
believe in it they usually give me a
different reason I said ok fine I said
do you believe in love yes can you give
me a scientific peer-reviewed paper that
proves that love exists no ok do you
believe in beauty yes same question same
answer no do you believe in trust do you
believe in loyalty do you believe in
human willpower you believe in freedom
do you believe in everything that makes
you a human being yes why and it's
always a different answer it's always
something different from a scientific
standard why is that I think that's very
curious yet when it comes to the
existence of God I have to validate all
of my beliefs including my all of my
religious beliefs that are alongside
that through scientific evidence it's
interesting
not to mention the fact that the very
standard itself that science is required
to believe or to justify a particular
belief or evidence scientific evidence
is required to justify a particular
belief is it none of itself a belief
that is not justified through scientific
evidence little philosophical conundrum
for all of you out there who want to
think about that I think it's very
fascinating but seeing all these double
standards made me realize that atheists
or generally the doubts that people have
about God's existence are not usually
rooted in intellectual or
intellectualization of their own beliefs
or any sort of rational argument have
there been rational arguments proposed
by atheists in the past yes of course
but generally the the climate today
seems to be that many atheists or many
people who doubt religion and the
existence of God tend to do so primarily
through these reasons primarily through
emotive psychological reasons that when
you examine them as I have you find so
many double standards that it's more
absurd to go down that path than to
continue with your own intellectual
traditions now Islam also has a view of
atheist this is not just I'm not just
gonna express my view but also the
traditional view of atheist and it also
has a way of dealing with atheism in the
same way that I've kind of told you just
now in a psychological and pragmatic
fashion in the Islamic tradition there
are a number of arguments for the
existence of God but generally they have
been used only with only with regard to
particular philosophical positions like
for example the Kalam cosmological
argument if you've ever heard of this
like the first you know everything that
comes into existence as a cause that was
really promoted simply to argue against
Aristotelian philosophers who were
saying that the the universe was eternal
it was never really against atheist per
se because most Arizonians
even God okay but Islam has generally in
Islamic scholars have generally viewed a
theism as a nonsense so nonsensical that
it didn't even require an actual
argument to go against and then
generally approached it from in
psychological matters Oh in the Islamic
tradition we have something called a pit
row and this is the predisposition to
belief or believing not just in God but
everything in general in reality okay
and the pit row basically tells us that
there is a purpose we see things with
purpose we can you see things with
design you see things with order okay we
see things as having a certain goal we
see ourselves in the same manner and
this this fifth row doesn't prove God's
existence believe it or not it doesn't
prove the existence of God but what it
does is it sets up a rational standard
within the mind of the human being to
infer that there is one it is a default
as it were a default position okay and
human beings are actually forced to
think this way we don't actually we
can't we don't voluntarily look at the
world as having purpose and design and
things like this we just do and this is
actually even been proven in a number of
ways
a lot of psychologists and even
neuroscientist have have made several
studies showing that belief or it's in
the supernatural in general is is
actually something that we can't control
it's something that we just naturally do
and a lot of people try to explain this
way suggesting well you know it's oh
it's an evolutionary byproduct you know
what our ancestors had to go through and
things like this they had to see purpose
and intention in order to survive but
it's very curious that the natural world
would impose such a standard minimize
that we would come up with something so
absurd quote unquote
and that we would continue to have this
sort of inclination
it seems to me even that if the natural
world was all that existed it would be
impossible that we would even have this
belief to begin with let me explain what
I mean by that
any of you have fish does anybody like
fish I like fish yeah I like fish okay
I'm weird all right okay so I used to
have a fish tank
55 gallon fish tank and I used to have
these little freshwater fish called
cichlids and they're vicious creatures
they eat meat I just put it that way
okay but they're beautiful
this is why I kept them but I never put
my hand in the tank and they're very
they're quite intelligent but they're
not so intelligent that I think that
they would be able to construct
mathematical models or anything or think
beyond their fish tank
okay there's they have this 55 gallon
fish tank this is all they know right
when they swim around the fish tank I
don't think they're thinking to
themselves am I on a living room I don't
think they're thinking to themselves
am I in a city I don't think they're
thinking to themselves is there anything
beyond my fish tank I don't think they
think they way they've not capable of
doing so in the same way though I think
humans also have that same limitation we
live in the world in the natural world
this is all we see this is all we are
okay we don't have any reference points
there's no sign saying god you know I
can't just reveal him on the stage here
okay
there are signs indeed we'll talk about
that but there's nothing like explicitly
telling me that there's God there right
okay God is beyond our world
so I like to ask this question why are
we thinking about it if we can't see
anything else but what we perceive in
here and in our own minds then why is
that he comes into our heads why is that
conception even exist in a world that
apparently doesn't have him as part of
his existence to me that doesn't make
any sentence much the same as it doesn't
make any sense to me that a fish would
think that he's anywhere else but a fish
tank
that the fishtank is all that exists the
same way I don't think humans can look
at the world and logically conclude from
that if the world is all there is that
there is a God so I find all this rather
curious and I'm wondering after asking
all these questions and bringing all
this to your attention and these
problems from a psychological and
pragmatic perspective if you find all
these things curious as well in a world
where God is a natural tendency in a
world where humans cannot be without God
in a world where everything is made
coherent because God exists in a world
where a hope and will are derived from
that one simple belief in a world where
most things we believe in don't require
the very evidence that atheists are
always asking for and yet it still
functions it still works in a world
where humanity has built civilizations
around this one idea though and I have
yet to see an atheist one ever exists as
a result of having lacking a belief in
the supernatural by the way there is no
atheist civilization that has ever
existed long enough to declare itself as
a result of lacking a belief in
something they have all ceased to exist
within a matter of decades in a world
where God is so necessary to the human
condition I wonder is it necessary to
ask does God exist
thank you very much just like a hair and
said I want to come to LA but I got it